do you realize that Ana ketogenic diet
wild-caught salmon is one of the best
protein / fat sources that you can
consume it has amazing amounts of
omega-3 fatty acids great complete
protein easy to digest if it's
wild-caught ok now there's a study yes
it was done in mice but I'll put a link
down below you can check it out study
involving chronic consumption of
farm-raised salmon dramatically
increased visceral fat ok that's fat
around your organs in the mid middle
part in Sun resistance and type 2
diabetes it creates a B C and a
low-grade inflammatory condition and
they detected it was the pesticides
dioxins and PCBs in that product that
did it now when you're actually
searching for salmon and you want a good
salmon there's two types Atlantic and
Pacific 95% of Atlantic is farm raised
so it has to say well caught and you're
not going to see an organic certificate
because they don't certify fish as
organic
now if the Civic is much more likely to
be wild-caught so if it says wild
Alaskan salmon it's totally fine coho
sake king pink chum these are all real
good to consume right here you can also
do it in a can just make sure it is well
caught and if they say it's fresh that's
meaningless it doesn't mean anything we
sell fresh fish right and when it says
flash-frozen it just means that they
freeze it right away which is totally
good so when you're doing a ketogenic
diet it's just really important to get
the quality fats and omega-3 is what
most people are missing so salmon is one
way to get it there's other fish you can
do but just make sure it's always well
caught thanks for watching
so we've been getting a lot of success
stories but I don't have your success
story yet so click the link down below
and upload you before and after I want
to actually hear about your success
story I want to see your
before-and-afters and every week we do
featured success stories so click the
link down below and share your success